Eric is next up in Lexington hi Eric how
are you I'm far better than I deserve
how are you better than I deserve sir
how can I help I had a question about
maintaining momentum on the long term
goals a little backstory my wife and I
got married about five years ago I
talked to her about wanting to get rid
of our debt
she agreed we went through the baby
steps got to got free baby step three
and then our momentum kind of fizzled we
didn't keep to our budget very well and
we didn't get into any new consumer debt
but we didn't really make any progress
on making extra payments on our mortgage
savings for some of the lows that we
knew were coming up and fast forward
about February we had a our third baby
and we didn't have the money saved up
for our portion of the bill and we had
to take out of our emergency fund and
that was kind of a wake-up call for us
good so we've kind of gotten back on
track gotten on to every dollar within
our budget every month again um and and
we could where else to catch sitting
down and planning for getting kind that
vision for our retirement in the future
and setting our legacy and just you know
one thing we saw with the with the
snowball was that we had those short
milestones that we would hit you know
one that paid off boom the next that
paid off in it you know a few months
later Zion we didn't we didn't have that
with our with our mortgage and these
long-term goals and that's that's not
why I give you suggestions for that's
the problems with baby steps four five
and six you're doing them simultaneously
you're saving for retirement fifteen
percent in baby step four you're saving
for kids college and baby step 5 baby
step six is paying off the house early
and they don't naturally lend themselves
to woohoo moments like paying off a debt
does and maybe step two and so it's it's
a little tougher to keep the emotional
momentum and what we've learned to do is
two or three things one is I'm going to
send you a copy of Chris Hogan's book
retire in spite
okay I just got that last week okay well
do you want to go up to Louisville to
his event next week all right yeah we
bout to he's doing an event there May
the 19th and or is that this week that's
this Thursday I'll give you a couple
tickets to that go up to his retire
inspired event okay okay but there's
there's a couple things you'll see there
that uh that we're learning a lot a lot
of people run into what you're running
into because they go so hard and I mean
it's like it's like a Braveheart yell
they're going crazy to get through baby
step three and then when they get
through baby step three they got their
emergency fund their debt free but the
house then it's more of a slog it's more
of a marathon through these other three
baby steps and what we've learned to do
is two things one is to very very
clearly as chris hogan says in HD define
your dream what does your retirement
dream look like and it needs to be
several components to it I mean whether
you want to increase your giving and you
want to travel or you always want to buy
a boat or I don't care what it is but
your retirement dream needs to be laid
out and cut a picture that out and it's
very clear and you and your spouse are
talking about it has a dollar amount
beside it so that then you're aiming at
it and so in a sense then you're
creating a debt snowball that says okay
my retirement dream looks like I need
two million dollars I've got you know
fourteen years to do that or whatever
okay it's a long slog in other words so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna break
that two million dollars down into parts
and I'm going to say you know when we
hit a quarter million we're going to
have a celebration when we hit a half
million we're gonna have another
celebration when we had a million we're
gonna have another celebration me and a
half are going to notice or whatever and
you lay it out there I'm making these
numbers up depending on what your income
is and how fast you're going to go
through those but set it up to where you
almost still got that thermometer on the
refrigerator door like you used to with
the debt snowball and you're feeling the
measurable progress we all need to spiel
in anything we're doing measurable
progress I'll give you an example that's
a metaphor for that too that that's how
important this is I was reading a an
employee a team member
satisfaction article the other day and
the the number one thing that team
members create satisfaction is not their
income it's not what you pay them it's
that they get to be a part of something
bigger than themselves and they can see
measurable results from their effort
they have to see that they're doing
something that matters and they can see
traction in their effort so when you've
got someone in all their Dunn's putting
lug nuts on a car all day long in an
assembly line it's very difficult to
stay motivated that's one of the reasons
most of the teams that do that now
change up jobs they don't do the same
job for six months they change up
they'll do steering wheels and then
they'll do fit wheels they'll just but
at least they're seeing the result
they're seeing sensing traction as a
part of it you don't get caught like a
cog in a wheel then and so that's what
you're seeing here you need to see this
traction we all do we need to feel this
traction we need to feel the progress
and so let's set yourself some so to
speak incremental milestones in the
process that you're aiming at and in the
only way those incremental milestones
are going to make sense and have energy
is if they're tied to a dream that
you've defined in high definition
okay and when you do those two you
combine those two things and so then you
jump on my Chris Hogan's website 360
Chris Hogan 360 com do the riq where you
see what you're you're retire inspired
quotient is what your number is that you
need and what numbers you got to do per
month to hit that number and the way
your need number is derived is based on
your dream again
it pulls you right back to that and so
what happened was you all had a clearly
defined goal and that kept you motivated
you were hitting milestones and had
traction towards the clearly defined
goal and when you came out the other
side of that goal you like ran through
the finish line at the race and then
there was no reason to get up the next
morning and go running because the race
was over and you quit eventually or you
went running a couple times and then you
quit and then the budget went away in
other words so now you got it back you
go okay I got to fix this and I got to
have some incremental steps that are
measurable that you can emotionally
celebrate that are taking you toward
that clearly defined high
definition goal and college you know so
if the kid is 14 go walk the college
campus smell the grass walk through the
Student Center attend a football game so
you got it all over you this is what
college looks like for junior so we got
to get juniors college account going and
it gives it a whole it gives it a touch
a sense of concrete it's not this vague
thing higher education somewhere off in
the clouds you know it's like this
that's really it they're going to wear
that color they're going to get they're
going to go that's where they're going
to eat their hamburger in the Student
Center and this is where that this is
going to happen and you just clearly
define this stuff to where it's in full
full-on HD at a TV go out last week in
an HDTV and I went down now they've got
4k Ultra TVs which doesn't make any
sense since hardly in these broadcasting
4k Ultra but it looks like those people
are going to jump out of that screen
right into my recliner it scares me half
to death it's so clear but um crazy so
but yeah it's that same kind of thing
you got to have this real clear vision
for the thing and that does it that is a
really excellent question Eric and I
believe me you're not the only one dude
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you